brach wrote in saying David are you a
constitutional originalist or a
constitutional pragmatist I wish I had a
longer answer but I'm a constitutional
pragmatist I mean I I don't know you
know the big picture for me is those who
pray at the altar of the Constitution
the constitutional fetishists as I've
named them over the last few years I
think that they are operating in
Fantasyland they are operating in a
world where they believe that the
Constitution is effectively a text so
sacred and so expertly ingeniously
written that despite having been written
in the 18th century it accounts for all
of the changes we've seen to society
during the 200 plus years during which
society has changed more quickly than at
any prior point in the history of Homo
sapiens and I just don't buy that yeah I
just don't I'm not sure that they would
argue that it's infallible necessarily I
mean they would point to the amendment
process yeah if there's something in the
Constitution that you don't like you can
go through a process of getting
something ratify them would also say
we're done with amendments we've made
all the necessary amendments and there
should be no more way more said the top
10 are great the Bill of Rights and
after that after that they're not that
great ya know yet there's some degree of
introspection when it comes to the
infallibility but no I think that the
Constitution in fact has become on many
political issues a way to impede actual
progress 2nd amendment is a big big way
where we are now taking a couple of
sentences written when you had 1 or 1
percent of the firepower and weaponry
that you have now and interpreting it to
mean in a completely absolute and sort
of Manichean black and white way what is
or isn't okay today with all of the
technology that exists I am a
constitutional pragmatist and I believe
that with every passing year and would
the continued advancement and change of
society the Constitution becomes more
and more outdated and necessary of
change yeah I think you have to be a
pragmatist because we have evolving
standards of decency right so maybe you
look at the 8th amendment cruel and
unusual punishment is banned from the
United States or what did that mean in
the late 1700s versus what it means
today I mean does that mean that stocks
and hanging people are totally fine now
very few people would argue that even
though that was the standard back then
and that actually might be in general I
I know about how being presented with
contradictory evidence to your beliefs
will often actually get people more
firmly planted in their pre-existing
belief even though we would hope that
when you're presented with sort of
counter points to your beliefs based in
facts you would say oh wait a second I
need to revisit my perspective on this
we know that but what Pat is suggesting
might be a good way to talk to
constitutional originalist which is
start with a particular amendment where
there's very little debate about the
fact that it is interpreted differently
today than it was when the amendment was
passed once you concede that one
Amendment's interpretation has shifted
because of changes in society then
you're just in the gray area right that
at that point it's okay well where do
you set the line on what can be
reinterpreted I think that my talk about
the commas in the Second Amendment at a
point at that point you're beyond
comment that's right
beyond commas in the Second Amendment I
think that that might be an effective
way to sort of try to get get people to
consider that constitutional pragmatism
does make more sense I am 100% on the
side of constitutional pragmatism if you
disagree with me tell me why write in
and tell me why and we can follow up
about that bonus show coming up after
the show if you're not a member or a
patron you don't get the bonus show I
think you would like the bonus show
that's my opinion I think Pat tends to
agree you can get access to the bonus
show two ways david pakman.com slash
membership or patreon.com slash david
pakman show